now Pakistan's former prime minister
Imran Khan has failed to appear before
an anti-corruption Court the government
body had summoned Khan regarding
investments in a university trust that
he and his wife run a large number of
police was deployed around his residence
in Lahore on Wednesday seventy-year-old
veteran politician has said police were
preparing to detain him again
Pakistan's Supreme Court has ruled his
arrest last week was illegal as
detention sparked violent protests
across the country let's go live to
Lahore where we can speak now to Al
jazeera's Osama bin Javed who is
standing by I believe you're outside
Imran Khan's residence what can you tell
us about what is happening there
that is true we are here at the Imran
Khan resident Zaman Park as it is known
where Imran Khan has been inside this is
where he tweeted that he is going to be
detained One More Time by the police as
we've heard from the police the deadline
for him to hand over what the police
calls are terrorists has expired and
we're shortly going to hear from police
officials who are expected to arrive
here there's more media here than uh
Imran Khan supporters unlike previous
times as we saw hundreds of Imran Khan
supporters had gathered here and they
wanted to uh stop the police from
arresting him the police says that it
does not want to arrest Imran Khan but
it wants him to hand over those people
who were involved in the violence on May
the 9th where not just public buildings
and government installations were set on
fire but also ambulances and schools
were torched and the government on its
path has said that it believes that it
was a a strategy by the leadership of
Pakistan party led by Imran Khan to
attack these installations says this is
a conspiracy it's not really the case
where they have been actually instigated
by other actors including some people
from the security agency so another high
drama political sagas you can see we're
expecting uh the police to come and
speak here shortly all the media is here
uh the roads leading to Zaman Park have
been blockaded the government wants to
go after all of those people with
civilian and Military courts rights
workers are concerned that this is going
to be this is going to trample on
people's rights to be tried in military
courts but also worth noting is the
number of leaders who have been arrested
from Imran Khan's party and also a few
coming out in the last 24 hours saying
that do not want to belong to a
political party with attacks on the
state
okay thank you for that update Al
jazeera's Osama bin Javed speaking to us
there outside Imran Khan's residence in
Lahore